well this one has certainly been a long
time coming we've known about the Dead
Space remake for a while now but outside
of some developer live streams showing
off early footage and that recent
trailer we haven't seen all that much
concrete gameplay that all changed a few
weeks ago when press got Hands-On with
the first three chapters of the game
equating to about three hours and boy is
there a lot to talk about personally I
haven't really been sure how to feel
about this remake going in I think the
original Dead Space is a masterpiece one
of the finest horror games you can play
today and despite its age I think the
art Direction holds up and it still
looks really good honestly it's harder
to see a dead space remake needing to
exist in the same way as games like
Resident Evil 2 and Final Fantasy VII
remake which so thoroughly redefined
their respective Originals both of which
are over two decades old so I went into
this thing kind of wondering how it's
going to justify its existence after
playing this remake I wouldn't say my
mind has completely changed on that
front I don't know if a dead space
remake needs to exist however I did have
a really excellent time with this game I
think EA motive has nailed the look and
feel of dead space and are bringing a
bunch of changes both big and small to
help create a fresh experience I was
super bummed when I hit the end of
chapter 3 because I just kind of wanted
to keep going and on a whole it has me
feeling really excited about dead space
again something I wasn't sure I would
feel again after the disappointment of
dead space 3. so if that's the goal of
this remake to revitalize the franchise
and remind people why Dead Space is so
damn good then I think it's going to be
a huge success so why don't we just Dive
Right In shall we
foreign
but first up gotta let you know that
while we did play the first three
chapters we could only capture chapters
two and three which is why I don't have
footage of the remakes chapter 1 to show
you so you might be wondering what type
of remake is this
really reductive for a moment and create
a line graph featuring video game
remakes on one end I'd have a game like
The Last of Us Part One which features a
complete visual overhaul but is
otherwise the same game we all remember
the other end of the spectrum would be
something like Final Fantasy VII remake
which completely reimagines The Story
characters and gameplay the Dead Space
remake sits somewhere in the middle at
its core based on these opening chapters
the game follows the same beats as the
original the level design is mostly the
same and at least so far the story is
the same but within that familiar
framework changes are made to either
update certain elements to match modern
game design or provide unexpected
wrinkles to the gameplay in order to
freshen up the experience for long time
fans for example our boyars at Clark
talks now they're out of fuel the
centrifuge is offline or Tethered to a 4
trillion ton payload without the engines
it's dragging us down to the planet can
you handle it alone
sure fix the centrifuge get the fuel
running then do a full restart this is
undoubtedly going to be a point of
contention for some people even back
when Isaac got his voice in Dead Space 2
there was a large part of the audience
that didn't care for it preferring the
silent Isaac of the original I think
there's a strong argument to be made for
both cases but for me personally I
actually really like that he talks now
it's not like they turned him into a
never-ending quip machine he just
engages in the conversations when people
call him it just feels more natural to
have him actually respond to people
talking to him or expressing a
personality at all such as concern for
the whereabouts of his girlfriend Nicole
it worked in the original when we didn't
know anything about Isaac and he was
kind of a blank slate but now that we've
had two games with him as an established
character I think it would be weird to
go back to him being silent it really
helps that Isaac's voice actor returns
for the role making the remix Isaac feel
more connected to the Isaac of Dead
Space 2 and 3. and it's not just Isaac
the rest of dead space's small cast of
characters has been updated with new
faces and voice actors The Script
follows the overall same structure but
lines have been Rewritten resulting in
characters like Hammond for example
having a slightly different personality
back in the original game Hammond kind
of came across as a hard ass barking
orders and trying to keep the mission
going despite how [ __ ] everything was
we can still do this get me the
captain's rig codes and we'll find
Nicole but in the remake he feels more
like a guy trying his best to keep a
level head and hold it together Isaac
have you heard from Daniel we were
attacked she ran the other way in turn
Kendra isn't immediately as hostile and
distrusting towards Hammond in the
beginning audio logs have also seen
changes and in some cases outright
change to be completely different it's
hard to judge right now how these
changes will shake out I don't think the
original script and dialogue was bad but
it certainly wasn't the best part of the
game either so I'm all for motive
choosing to update it the real question
is whether more serious deviations will
happen in later chapters of course a big
part of a remake is its visuals and holy
heck this game is gorgeous I mean just
look at it everything in the game has
seen some sort of update and some of the
changes are pretty mind-blowing the most
exciting part about this is not just
that it looks nice though it's that
these modern visuals can mix up and
enhance the horror career the game is a
lot darker overall and that means more
opportunities to show off new lighting
techniques for example I really love how
the shots on your weapon now light up
the space around them creating this
really intense feel I mean just compare
how it looks here with the pulse rifle
in Dead Space original versus how it
looks in the remake
[Applause]
something really important though is
that I think EA motive has nailed the
aesthetic of the original remakes can
often struggle to maintain the
original's looking tone going too far or
ending up feeling uncomfortably
different not the case here I just
thought oh yeah sure this looks better
but this is what I picture when I think
of dead space It wasn't until I got home
and compared the two that I realized how
much was actually that different one of
the changes I quite liked was the
inclusion of circuit breakers next to a
lot of the power socket puzzles when you
place the um Power rectangle yeah let's
let's go with that when you place the
power rectangle into the power socket
the breaker will light up you then have
to choose where power is diverted to the
first one you come across teaches you
the concept by having you pick between
powering a door or an elevator then a
later example requires you to turn on
the power to a console but doing so you
have to make the choice between turning
off the lights
or the oxygen
the Remake also lifts the control scheme
and mechanics from Dead Space 2 and
plops it in here
that means snap your controls using the
B button as a health pack and stomp it
on enemies to collect their goodies
something I actually forgot wasn't in
the original you might think how this
affects the pacing of dead space but
because the Remake was built around
these updates they kind of compensate
the enemies for these changes so I found
the pacing and rhythm of combat to feel
pretty much the same I think it still
has that slower horror Pace that the
original Dead Space is known for and
that's a good thing same goes with the
weapons which all feel good and the way
you expect an interesting change is that
you'll actually find some of the weapons
naturally as you play rather than
collecting their Blueprints and
purchasing them at the shop for example
I found the flamethrower right before
entering the area in chapter 3 where the
walls are covered in flesh and they
start throwing these little Annoying
guys that are best handled with you know
the flamethrower I'm curious if this is
going to be the case with every weapon
or if there will still be ones you pick
up blueprints for blueprints for ammo
and other items are still a thing so
it's not like you aren't doing that as
well so you might have seen the
developers talk about how the ishimura
is now a more seamless map with no
loading times and you can walk from one
end of the ship all the way to the other
and when I first heard this I thought to
myself well that's neat but how does
that actually play out the original game
is separated very cleanly from chapter
to chapter and you weren't even able to
travel back to previous areas well it
turns out in this version of Dead Space
the good old ishimura transit system is
a bit busted now which means instead
they've added these new sections to help
bridge chapters for example when
traveling from chapter one to two you
take the service tunnel to get into the
medical Bay or for chapter 3 you
actually have to head back to the hangar
and travel through a new zero gravity
area to get into engineering I think
this is a great change not only is it a
neat way to help bridge the game
together as a seamless experience it
also kind of breaks up the
repetitiveness of using the tram at the
beginning and end of every level now
that said and once you unlock the train
you can use it at any time to return to
previous locations it's unclear to what
extent you want to return to previous
areas but one reason might be for the
new security locks you'll find doors and
lockers with a security level and during
certain story beats you'll unlock higher
tiers and then you can go back to these
locked rooms if you want to collect
extra resources these locks are
basically replacements for the original
node lock doors in the original where
you had to waste a power node to open up
a door and well hope that that door had
good stuff to find because otherwise hey
you wasted a power node that means in
this version backtracking is more linked
to narrative progression I'm not sure
entirely how I feel about this I did
sort of like the risk reward of using a
power node and hoping you got something
good but as long as it's balanced right
I think it's a fine change another
reason to return to previous areas might
be for side missions that's right Dead
Space 1 has optional Quest now based on
what we've played these seem to be
pretty sparring as a result only one
side mission we encountered in the first
three chapters what's interesting is
that this mission was actually about
Nicole Isaac's girlfriend when he
visited the medical Bay the place where
Nicole worked Isaac naturally brings up
wanting to find her prompting the side
mission this basically means going
slightly off the beaten path to find
hologram recordings of her in an attempt
to discover what happened to her this
Sparks a scavenger hunt that essentially
encompasses the entire ship I love the
idea of using small side objectives to
help flesh out and see Nicole early in
as a character which ties really well to
Isaac having a personality now I'm very
curious to see how many of these
optional side missions there are in the
game and how the potential for
backtracking affects the overall pacing
I'm feeling really good about what I've
played of this remake it's pretty clear
EA motive gets what makes Dead Space
such a classic and I think they're
treating the changes of a lot of care
and respect at least in these first
three chapters intriguingly when fellow
game spotter Jordan Renee interviewed
the developers they didn't bring up
events from the final four chapters that
covers the part of the game on The Valor
all the way up into the game's final
conclusion for as much as I've praised
the original as a masterpiece this whole
time I gotta be honest the final few
chapters are big stinkers for me it's a
huge drop in both storytelling and
gameplay quality and the conclusion is
really lackluster while this is just
speculation on my part I think the fact
that the developers aren't sharing what
the final chapters of the Remake are
like implies a much greater level of
change for the rest of the game that's
something I would personally really like
to see and could be the thing that makes
this remake go from a good update to the
original to something that could even
surpass the original maybe hopefully
we'll just have to wait and see for
ourselves when the game comes out on
January 27th and hey if you're dying to
know even more about dead space after
watching this video I highly recommend
heading over to gamespot.com and reading
Jordan remains Impressions he's got his
own take on the Remake plus some insight
from the developers link is in the
description